القوه الامريكيه في سوريا مهدده بالقتل
ومرحله جديده من العنف ستبدا لطرد
الولايات المتحده من المنطقه هكذا تخطط
ايران وروسيا وفق ما كشفته وثائق مسربه
حصلت عليها صحيفه واشنطن بوستا الوثائق
السريه اظهرت ان طهران تسلح فصائل مواليه
لها في سوريا وتدربهم على استخدام متفجرات
خارقه للدروع تستهدف تحديدا المركبات
العسكريه الامريكيه وقتل جنود الجيش
الامريكي باشراف مباشر من وحده فيلق القدس
الايراني ولن تقتصر الهجمات على البر فقط
بل ستصاعد طهران هجماتها جوا عبر شن ضربات
صاروخيه وهجمات من طائرات مسيره على
القوات الامريكيه في سوريا
موسكو وطهران ودمشق تعمل على الاطاحه
بالنفوذ الامريكي في المنطقه انطلاقا من
سوريا وهو هدف طال انتظاره قد يسمح للرئيس
بشار الاسد باستعاده المحافظات الشرقيه
التي يسيطر عليها الاكراد المدعومون من
الولايات المتحده كما تقول الوثائق التي
اوضحت ان الهجمات الايرانيه هدفها ايضا رد
على الضربات الاسرائيليه على قواتها ويقدر
عدد عناصر القوات الامريكيه في سوريا بنحو
900 فرد معززين بمئات المتعاقدين الاخرين
لمنع عوده مقاتل داعش واحباط الطموحات
الايرانيه والروسيه وتوفير قاعده نفوذ
لاهداف استراتيجيه امريكيه اخرى وفق
التقرير
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات